dann hörte ich die aussprache und
erteile das wort der
fraktionsvorsitzende afd wirkte alles
weiter
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter präsident sehr geehrte
damen und herren liebe kollegen diese
aussprache hat züge des sozialen
wir sprechen über einen haushalt ich
kann mich
stellen
nachdem eine bundesregierung arbeiten
soll
die eigentlich schon gescheitert ist die
zerstritten und innerlich zerfallen ist
eine regierung gehen einzelne
bestandteile mal mit und mal
gegeneinander vor allem aber mit sich
selbst und mit dem eigenen überleben
beschäftigt sind
die dauerkrise in der sich diese
regierung seit ihrem mühseligen
zustandekommen befindet durchzieht auch
das vorliegende zahlenwerk dieser
haushalt ist ein haushalt des weiter so
ein weiter so in dem sie frau
bundeskanzlerin sich eingerichtet haben
dass unser land sich aber schon lange
nicht mehr leisten kann nicht finanziell
und nicht gesellschaftlich und weder
innen noch außenpolitisch davon wollen
sie aber nichts hören
ihre weigerung fehler zu erkennen und
fehlentscheidungen zu korrigieren ist
notorisch die haushaltsberatung die
hinter uns liegen haben das ein ums
andere mal bestätigt herr kauder
nichts ist gelöst in deutschland frau
merkel auf keine einzige der drängenden
zukunftsfragen unseres landes haben sie
und ihre regierung ein
antwort die staatsquote die staatsquote
ist immer noch viel zu hoch
deutschland braucht eine radikale
steuerreform
die für verdiener den grundbedarf aller
haushaltsmitglieder mit vollem umfang
und in angemessener höhe steuerfrei
stellt sie nehmen das geld der bürger
das nicht zuletzt die derzeit noch
aktiven und gut ausgebildeten baby
boomer reichlich erwirtschaften freuen
sich über scheinbar glänzende auszahlen
die ihnen die fortwährende schleichende
enteignung der bürger durch die
nullzinspolitik der ezb verschafft und
verschleudern den wohlstand unseres
landes als gäbe es kein morgen
steigende staatseinnahmen sind für sie
kein grund offensichtlich den bürgern
das zuviel abgenommen
auch wieder zurückzugeben liebe finden
sie neue ausgabe tatbestände für noch
mehr umverteilung für noch mehr klientel
politik und ideologie projekte für die
rettung des euro und natürlich für die
alimentierung von millionen von asyl
einwanderern
dabei würde ja
dabei würde der wohlstand und die
finanziellen spielräume die bürger und
unternehmen trotz aller widrigkeiten
immer noch der wirtschaften dramatisch
und dringend gebraucht zum beispiel um
unsere bildungssysteme auf vordermann zu
bringen und um unsere sozialsysteme
zukunfts und demographie festzumachen
sie gründen eine kommission zur
sicherung der altersvorsorge über das
jahr 2025 hinaus
sie geben verhohlen aus von stabilen
beiträgen und rentenniveaus über die
ressourcen die dafür benötigt würden
werfen sie mit vollen händen zum fenster
hinaus schlimmer noch sie sägen und
fackeln mit hingabe an den grundlagen
und wurzeln unseres bisherigen
wohlstandes herum mit der unbelehrbare
weiterverfolgung einer gescheiterten
energiewende die außer dem höchsten
strompreise in der westlichen welt
sinkender versorgungssicherheit und
ressourcen verschleuderung in jährlich
zweistelliger milliarden-höhe die nichts
gebracht hat und mit einer mobilitäts
wände mit einer mobilitäts wendet in
wahrheit ein unverhohlener von
bornierten ideologen angezettelten krieg
gegen das automobil und die anhängende
industrie und mittelständische
wirtschaft mit allen ihren
arbeitsplätzen ist
dort sehr geehrte damen und herren
werden nämlich die steuergelder
erwirtschaftet die sie so gern und
reichlich verteilen nicht zuletzt haben
sich selbst denn das einzige was ihre
chaos koalition in gut drei monaten
geräuschlos und schnell über die bühne
gebracht hat war ja die dreiste erhöhung
der staatlichen parteienfinanzierung für
sie selbst
[Applaus]
handwerksmeister und industrie
facharbeiter handel und gewerbe schaffen
produktivität und wohlstand und nicht
steuerfinanzierte sozialpädagogen und
sender professor rixe die euro krise
hängt noch immer wie ein damoklesschwert
über deutschland die rettung
griechenland sei abgeschlossen heißt es
dabei ist die vermeintliche abschluss
regelung nur eine weitere kreditlinie
für und hoffnungslos überschuldetes land
ist die verbraucht kommt der ruf nach
dem nächsten rettungspaket
die 229 milliarden euro die griechenland
als hilfs kredite von den euro staaten
bekommen hat dürften weg sein die
fiktion
sie würden eines tages zurückgezahlt ist
ein billiger bilanztrick und ganz
ehrlich das wissen sie auch und
eindringlich dürfen auch die tage zwei
forderungen der bundesbank an andere
zentralbanken des eurosystem sein die
inzwischen an der millionengrenze
kratzen das deutsche export wunder würde
über unbegrenzte blankoschecks
finanziert reale industriegüter
eingetauscht gegen theoretische
forderung und das risiko trägt wie immer
der deutsche steuerzahler
ich stelle die frage
was wenn die krise in italien offen
ausbricht das allein für fast die hälfte
der deutschen tage zwei außenstände
steht ohne an die folgen zu denken
treiben sie die banken haftungs und
transferunion voran
machen sie dem französischen präsidenten
makro sagen für 1 euro zone budget mit
dem das haushaltsrecht der nationalen
parlamente ausgehebelt werden soll
und all das nur um sich in europa den
anschein eines rückhalt zu erkaufen der
ihnen im eigenen land unter den händen
cent haben regierungen in so kurzer zeit
so viele zukunfts für tekken aufgeladen
und es trotz guter ausgangslage so
fahrlässig herunter gewirtschaftet wie
die von ihnen seit 13 jahren angeführten
koalition und das unwürdige schauspiel
dass sie uns in den vergangenen tagen
und wochen zugemutet haben springt
allerdings alles bisher dagewesene
ihre weigerung
den er wegen ihrer willkommenskultur
einzugestehen und die notwendigen
maßnahmen zur kurskorrektur wenigstens
einzuleiten hatten aktuelle
regierungskrise ausgelöst die mit ihrem
büro sieg über horst seehofer noch
längst nicht ausgestanden ist sie
demontieren ihren innenminister weil er
damit droht nach drei jahren
willkürlicher außerkraftsetzung
wenigstens teilweise wieder geltendes
gesetz anzuwenden
und um das zu verhindern missbrauchen
sie ihre richtlinienkompetenz schauen
sie einmal ins grundgesetz
lassen sie es sich von einem
verfassungsrechtler erklären die
richtlinienkompetenz ist nicht dazu da
recht und verfassung dauerhaft außer
kraft zu setzen
der britische politikwissenschaftler end
technik dies bemerkte nach ihrer
willkürlichen einseitigen
außerkraftsetzung geltenden rechts im
september 2015
deutschland werde als durchgeknallter
hippie stadt wahrgenommen
der zum rationalen handel nicht mehr
fähig sei und die wahrnehmung im übrigen
ist sich besser geworden vom standpunkt
einer wachsenden zahlen unserer nachbarn
im norden süden osten und westen ist
deutschland einen narren haus und im
kanzleramt ist die zentrale und von den
eu migrations gipfel haben sie ein
bündel von vagen absichtserklärungen und
unverbindlichen allgemeinplätzen
mitgebracht die sie uns als europäische
lösung verkaufen wollen reihenweise aber
widersprechen andere eu-staaten ihrer
eigenwilligen interpretation mit denen
sie sich ihre leere hände schönreden
wollen
deutschland ist unter ihrer begebung von
motor und stabilitätsanker zum chaos
faktor geworden
das lassen wir uns mal hier ganz klar
sagen
und jetzt der kompromiss mit der csu mit
denen sie die schwesterpartei noch mal
auf linie gebracht haben während der
andere koalitionspartner schon wieder
erläutert horst seehofer hat auf seine
ursprüngliche hauptforderung wenigstens
bereits registrierte und mit
einreiseverbot belegt asylbewerber schon
an der grenze abzuweisen verzichtet und
darf innenminister bleiben was heißt das
konkret statt geltendes recht
durchzusetzen trägt seehofer trägt die
csu die herrschaft des unrechts weiter
mit so wie vor zwei jahren als er eine
organ
kg vor dem bundesverfassungsgericht
gegen die politik der offenen grenze im
ankündigte und nie lieferte beliefert
hat dafür jetzt die afg
bundestagsfraktion
herr seehofer
schade sie hätten ihre ehre wirklich
retten können als der mann der
deutschland ein neuanfang ermöglicht
und jetzt wird man sich als sie an sie
als agonie verlängerer der ära merkel
erinnern und wie lange noch frau merkel
wollen sie unsere geduld strapazieren
und dieses unwürdige schauspiel in die
länge ziehen was muss eigentlich noch
alles geschehen um sie zu einsicht zu
bringen
wie lange wollen sie uns noch mit blogs
mit pseudo abkommen plan ankündigungen
voller hintertüren und seitenausgang
hinhalten aus denen doch nie etwas wird
sie sind auf der ganzen linie
gescheitert sie haben nichts erreicht
außer mit allen kniffen und listen noch
etwas länger auf dem sessel einer
kanzlerin zu sitzen die einer längst
schon innerlich zerbrochenen koalition
vorsteht und dafür spalten sie
deutschland dafür spalten sie europa
dafür spalten uns zerlegen sie ihre
wackelige koalition und am ende ihre
eigene partei machen sie also den
trauerspiel ein ende und treten sie
bitte ab
[Applaus]